Cet air sublime, la musique d'arrivée,
"La Marche des Eléphants" (sic) d'Aida, est le morceau que j'ai choisi pour mes obsèques,
(Rires)
et vous pouvez comprendre pourquoi. Elle est triomphale.
Je vais... Je ne sentirai rien, mais si je le pouvais,
j'aurais un sentiment de triomphe d'avoir tout simplement vécu
d'avoir vécu sur cette sublime planète,
et d'avoir eu la possibilité de comprendre
en partie pourquoi je me suis trouvé ici avant de ne plus m'y trouver.
Pouvez vous comprendre mon pittoresque accent anglais ?
Comme tout le monde, j'ai été fasciné par la séance sur les animaux hier.
Robert Full, Frans Lanting et d'autres,
la beauté de ce qu'ils ont montré.
La seule légère dissonance a eu lieu quand Jeffrey Katzenberg a dit du mustang,
"la plus belle des créatures que Dieu ait mise sur Terre"
Alors bien sûr, nous savons qu'il ne voulait pas vraiment dire ça,
mais dans ce pays, en ce moment, on n'est jamais trop prudent.
(Rires)
Je suis biologiste, et le théorème central de notre discipline : la théorie de la création,
la théorie de l'évolution de Darwin via la sélection naturelle.
Partout dans les milieux professionnels, elle est acceptée universellement.
Dans les milieux non professionnels en dehors des Etats-Unis, elle est largement inconnue.
Par contre dans les milieux non professionnels aux Etats-Unis,
elle soulève tellement d'hostilité,
(Rires)
qu'il est raisonnable de dire que les biologistes américains sont en guerre.
La guerre est si préoccupante actuellement,
des procès surgissant dans un état après l'autre,
que j'ai pensé que j'avais quelque chose à dire à ce sujet.
Si vous voulez savoir ce que j'ai à dire à propos du Darwinisme à proprement parler,
j'ai bien peur que vous deviez aller voir mes livres,
que vous ne trouverez pas dans la librairie dehors.
(Rires)
Les procès récents
concernent souvent une soi-disant nouvelle version du créationnisme,
appelée le dessein intelligent, ou DI.
Ne soyez pas dupe. Il n'y a rien de neuf dans le DI.
C'est juste du créationnisme sous un autre nom
Rebaptisé, et je choisis ce mot délibérément,
(Rires)
pour des raisons stratégiques et politiques.
Les arguments des prétendus théoriciens du DI
sont les mêmes vieux arguments qui ont été réfuté encore et encore,
depuis Darwin jusqu'à nos jours.
Il existe un lobby de l'évolution très efficace
qui coordonne la lutte au nom de la science,
et je tente de faire tout mon possible pour les aider,
mais ils s'énervent quand des gens comme moi osent mentionner
que nous sommes athées autant qu'évolutionnistes.
Pour eux nous jouons les trouble-fêtes, et vous pouvez comprendre pourquoi.
Les créationnistes n'ayant pas le moindre argument scientifique cohérent pour défendre leur position
se rabattent sur la phobie populaire envers l'athéisme.
Enseignez l'évolution à vos enfants en cours de biologie,
et ils se tourneront bientôt vers la drogue, le grand banditisme et la sexualité précoce.
(Rires)
En effet, les théologiens éduqués, à commencer par le Pape,
soutiennent évidemment fermement l'évolution.
Ce livre, "Le Dieu de Darwin", de Kenneth Miller,
est une des attaques sur le Dessein Intelligent les plus efficaces
que je connaisse, et elle est d'autant plus efficace
qu'elle est écrite par un fervent chrétien.
On pourrait dire de gens comme Kenneth Miller qu'ils sont un don du Ciel pour le lobby de l'évolution
(Rires)
car ils dénoncent le mensonge que l'évolutionnisme serait en fait
équivalent à l'athéisme
D'un autre côté, les gens comme moi jouent les trouble-fêtes.
Et maintenant je vais dire quelque chose de bien à propos des créationnistes.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose que je fais souvent, donc écoutez attentivement.
(Rires)
Je pense qu'ils ont raison sur un sujet.
Je pense qu'ils ont raison de dire que l'évolution
est fondamentalement hostile à toute religion.
J'ai déjà dit que beaucoup d'évolutionnistes particuliers, comme le Pape,
sont aussi religieux, mais je pense qu'ils se leurrent.
Je pense qu'une compréhension rigoureuse du Darwinisme
est profondément hostile à la foi religieuse.
Il peut vous sembler que je m'apprête à prêcher l'athéisme,
et je tiens à vous rassurer, ce n'est pas le cas.
Devant un public aussi éclairé que cela... que celui-la
ce serait prêcher un converti.
Non, je veux vous pousser à faire...
(Rires)
je veux vous pousser à faire de l'athéisme militant.
(Applaudissements)
Mais c'est le présenter négativement.
Si je voulais... Si j'avais intérêt à la préservation de la foi religieuse,
je serais réellement effrayé par le pouvoir qu'a la théorie de l'évolution,
et la science en général, mais l'évolution en particulier,
à inspirer et à séduire, précisément parce qu'elle est athée.
Bien... Le problème le plus délicat auquel toute théorie biologique de l'évolution se frotte
est d'expliquer la phénoménale improbabilité statistique des êtres vivants.
Une improbabilité statistique dans le sens d'une bonne conception,
la complexité est un autre mot pour ça.
L'argument créationniste standard, et il n'y en a qu'un, ils se réduisent tous à celui-là,
démarre d'une improbabilité statistique.
Les êtres vivants sont trop complexes pour être apparu par chance,
ils doivent donc avoir un concepteur.
Évidemment, cet argument se tire une balle dans le pied.
N'importe quel concepteur capable de concevoir quelque chose de vraiment complexe
doit être encore plus complexe lui-même, sans même parler
des autres choses qu'il est censé pouvoir faire,
comme pardonner les péchés, bénir les mariages, écouter les prières...
favoriser notre camp dans une guerre...
(Rires)
désapprouver notre vie sexuelle, etc.
La complexité est le problème que toute théorie biologique doit résoudre,
et c'est impossible en postulant un agent encore plus complexe,
et ainsi agraver le problème.
La sélection naturelle de Darwin est brillament élégante
car elle résout le problème de la complexité
en n'utilisant rien d'autre que la simplicité.
En bref, elle le résout en fournissant une rampe douce
d'incréments successifs graduels.
Mais ici, je souhaite simplement affirmer
que l'élégance de la théorie de Darwin est corrosive pour la religion
précisément parce qu'elle est si élégante, si sobre, si puissante,
si puissamment économe.
Elle possède la sobriété austère d'un admirable pont suspendu.
La théorie de Dieu n'est pas seulement une mauvaise théorie.
Elle s'avère être intrinsèquement incapable de faire ce qui est attendu d'elle.
Revenons-en maintenant à la stratégie et le lobby de l'évolution,
j'affirme que jouer les trouble-fêtes pourrait bien être exactement ce qu'il faut faire.
Mon approche pour attaquer le créationnisme est différente de celle du lobby de l'évolution.
Mon approche pour attaquer le créationnisme est d'attaquer la religion dans son ensemble,
et c'est ici que je dois constater l'existence d'un remarquable tabou
contre toute critique de la religion.
et pour cela je vais reprendre les mots du regretté Douglas Adams,
un ami très cher qui, s'il n'est jamais venu à TED,
aurait clairement dû être invité.
(Richard Saul Wurman : Il l'a été.)
Richard Dawkins : Il l'a été. Bien. Je pensais qu'il avait dû l'être.
Il commence ce discours qui a été enregistré à Cambridge
peu avant sa mort.
Il commence en expliquant comme la science fonctionne en testant des hypothèses
qui sont conçues comme étant réfutables, puis il poursuit.
Je cite, "La Religion ne semble pas fonctionner de cette façon.
En son coeur existent certaines idées que l'on dit saintes ou sacrées
Ce que cela signifie c'est : voici une idée ou une notion
à propos de laquelle vous n'avez pas le droit de dire quoi que ce soit de mal.
Vous n'avez pas le droit. Pourquoi pas? Parce que vous n'avez pas le droit.
(Rires)
Pourquoi serait-il parfaitement légitime de soutenir les Républicains ou les Démocrates,
ce modèle économique plutôt que celui là, Macintosh et non Windows,
alors qu'avoir une opinion à propos du commencement de l'univers,
à propos de qui l'a crée... Non, c'est sacré.
Nous sommes donc habitués à ne pas remettre en cause les idées religieuses
et il est intéressant de constater la fureur que Richard soulève
quand il le fait." Il voulait dire moi, pas celui-là.
"Tout le monde est absolument furieux à ce propos,
car on ne doit pas dire ça, et pourtant quand on regarde ça rationnellement
il n'y a pas de raisons pour que ces idées ne soient pas ouvertes au débat
comme n'importe quelles autres, sauf que d'une certaine façon nous nous sommes mis d'accord
pour qu'elles ne le soient pas." Et ceci clôt la citation de Douglas.
De mon point de vue, la science n'est pas seulement corrosive envers la religion,
la religion est corrosive envers la science.
Elle enseigne aux gens à se satisfaire de pseudo-explications surnaturelles et triviales,
et les aveugle au sujet des explications merveilleuses et réelles que nous avons à portée.
Elle leur apprend à accepter l'autorité, la révélation et la foi
au lieu de toujours mettre l'accent sur les preuves.
Voilà Douglas Adams, superbe photo tirée de son livre, "La dernière chance de voir".
Alors, voilà un journal scientifique typique, Quarterly Review of Biology.
Et je vais mettre en place, en tant qu'éditeur invité,
un numéro spécial sur le thème "Un astéroïde a-t-il tué les dinosaures?".
Et le premier article est un article scientifique standard
présentant une pièce à conviction, "Une couche d'iridium à la frontière K-T,
un cratère au Yucatan datée par la méthode Potassium-Argon,
montrent qu'un astéroïde a tué les dinosaures."
Un article scientifique parfaitement ordinaire.
Voilà maintenant l'article suivant, "Le président de la Royal Society,
s'est vu garantir une ferme intime conviction" (Rires)
"... qu'un astéroïde a tué les dinosaures."
(Rires)
"Il a été révélé au Professeur Huxtane de façon privée
qu'un astéroïde a tué les dinosaures."
(Rires)
"Le professeur Hordley a été élevé
dans la foi totale et inconditionnelle
(Rires)
qu'un astéroïde a tué les dinosaures."
"Le professeur Hawkins a promulgué un dogme officiel
engageant tous les loyaux hawkinsiens
à croire qu'un astéroïde a tué les dinosaures."
(Rires)
C'est bien sûr inconcevable.
Mais imaginez...
(Applaudissements)
en 1987 un journaliste a demandé a George Bush père
s'il reconnaissait le patriotisme et la citoyenneté égale
aux américains athées.
La réponse de M. Bush est tristement célèbre.
"Non, je ne pense pas que les athées doivent être considéré comme des citoyens
ni comme des patriotes.
Nous sommes une nation unie sous l'aile de Dieu"
La bigoterie de Bush n'étais pas une erreur isolée,
une parole irréfléchie prononcée dans le feu de l'action, puis retirée.
Il s'y est tenu malgré des appels répétés à la clarification ou à la rétractation.
Il le pensait vraiment.
Plus précisément, il savait que cela ne présentait aucune menace pour son élection, bien au contraire.
Les démocrates comme les républicains affichent leur piété
s'ils veulent être élus. Ces deux partis invoquent une nation unie sous l'aile de Dieu.
Qu'aurait dit Thomas Jefferson ?
Accessoirement, je ne suis pas très souvent fier d'être anglais,
mais on ne peut s'empêcher de faire la comparaison.
(Applaudissements)
En réalité, qu'est-ce qu'un athée ?
Un athée est simplement quelqu'un qui ressent pour Yahvé
ce que tout bon chrétien ressent pour Thor, Baal ou le Veau d'Or.
Comme cela a déjà été dit, nous sommes tous athée envers la plupart des dieux
auxquels l'humanité n'ait jamais cru. Certains vont simplement un dieu plus loin.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et quelque soit notre définition de l'athéisme, il s'agit certainement d'une croyance théorique
qu'une personne a le droit d'avoir sans être calomniée
comme étant un non-citoyen inéligible et antipatriotique.
Néanmoins, c'est un fait établi qu'affimer être athée
revient à se présenter comme M. Hitler ou Mlle. Belzébuth.
Et tout cela vient du fait que les athées
sont perçus comme une minorité étrange et excentrique.
Natalie Angier a écrit un article assez triste dans le New Yorker,
disant à quel point elle se sentait seule en tant qu'athée.
Elle a clairement l'impression de faire partie d'une minorité assiégée,
mais à propos, combien d'américains athées peut on dénombrer ?
La dernière étude est étonnamment encourageante.
La chrétienté prend bien sûr la part du lion
avec près de 160 millions de personnes.
Mais quel est le second groupe le plus important selon vous,
surpassant en nombre de façon probante les confessions juive, 2,8 millions, musulmane, 1,1 millions
les hindous, les boudhistes et toutes les autres religions réunies ?
Le second groupe le plus grand, avec presque 30 millions de personnes,
est celui décrit comme non religieux ou laïque.
On ne peut s'empêcher de se demander pourquoi les politiciens à la recherche des votes
sont réputés si intimidés par le pouvoir du lobby juif, par exemple.
L'état d'Israël semble devoir son existence même
aux votes du lobby juif américain, reléguant au même instant
les non religieux au néant politique.
Ce vote laïque, s'il était correctement mobilisé
serait neuf fois plus important que le vote juif.
Pourquoi cette bien plus grande minorité
ne fait-elle rien pour utiliser son pouvoir politique ?
Voilà pour la quantité. Qu'en est-il de la qualité ?
Y a-t-il une quelconque corrélation, positive ou négative,
entre l'intelligence et la tendance à être croyant ?
(Rires)
L'étude que j'ai cité, l'étude ARIS,
n'a pas découpé ses données par classe socio-professionnelle, par niveau d'éducation,
par Q.I. ou quoi que ce soit d'autre.
Mais un article récent de Paul G. Bell dans le magazine Mensa
fournit des indices.
Mensa, comme vous le savez, est une organisation internationnale
pour personnes ayant un Q.I. très élevé.
Et à partir d'une méta-étude de la littérature,
Bell conclut que, je cite, "Des 43 études menées depuis 1927
sur la relation entre le sentiment religieux et l'intelligence ou le niveau d'éducation,
toutes sauf quatre ont trouvé une relation inverse.
C'est à dire, plus l'intelligence ou le niveau d'éducation d'une personne est élevé,
moins cette personne risque d'être croyante.
Je n'ai pas vu les 42 études originales et je ne peux pas commenter cette méta-étude
mais je voudrais voir plus d'études de ce genre.
Et je sais qu'il y a, si je pouvais pouvais faire un peu de pub ici,
qu'il y a des gens dans le public
qui pourraient facilement financer une énorme étude pour régler la question,
et j'avance cette idée, pour ce qu'elle vaut.
Mais laissez moi vous montrer des chiffres
qui ont été correctement publié et analysé
sur un groupe particulier, à savoir, les scientifiques de haut niveau.
En 1998, Larson et Witham
ont sondé la crème des scientifiques américains,
ceux qui ont eu l'honneur d'être élu à la National Academy of Sciences,
et au sein de ce groupe trié sur le volet,
la croyance personnelle en Dieu n'atteint qu'un renversant sept pour-cent.
Environ 20 pour-cent sont agnostiques, et le reste pourrait raisonnablement être appelé athées.
Des résultats similaires sont obtenus au sujet de la croyance en l'immortalité.
Au sein des biologistes, les chiffres sont encore plus bas,
5,5 pour-cent seulement croient en Dieu. Physiciens : 7,5 pour-cent.
Je n'ai pas vu de chiffres équivalents pour l'élite des chercheurs
dans d'autres domaines, comme l'histoire ou la philosophie,
mais je serais surpris s'ils étaient différents.
Nous avons donc atteint une situation tout à fait remarquable,
une discordance grotesque entre l'intelligentsia américaine
et l'électorat américain.
L'opinion philosophique concernant la nature de l'univers,
qui est celle de la vaste majorité des meilleurs scientifiques américains
et probablement celle de la majorité de l'intelligentsia en général,
est tellement détestée par l'électorat américain
que nul candidat à une élection populaire n'ose l'affirmer publiquement.
Si j'ai raison, cela signifie que les postes importants
dans le plus grand pays du monde
sont interdits aux mieux qualifiés, l'intelligentsia,
à moins qu'ils soient prêts à mentir sur de leurs convictions.
Pour le dire abruptement, les opportunités politiques américaines
sont grandement défavorables à ceux
qui sont à la fois intelligents et honnêtes.
(Applaudissements)
Je ne suis pas citoyen de ce pays, j'espère donc qu'il n'apparaitra pas déplacé
que je suggère qu'il faut faire quelque chose.
(Rires)
Et j'ai déjà donné un indice sur ce quelque chose.
De ce que j'ai vu de TED, je pense que ce pourrait être l'endroit idéal pour le lancer.
Encore une fois, j'ai peur que cela ne coûte de l'argent.
Nous avons besoin d'une campagne de prise de conscience
et de coming-out pour les athées américains.
(Rires)
Ce pourrait se rapprocher de la campagne menée par les homosexuels
il y a quelques années
mais que le ciel nous empêche de nous abaisser à outer publiquement
des personnes contre leur volonté.
Dans la plupart des cas, les gens qui se dévoileront
aideront à détruire le mythe selon lequel quelque chose ne va pas chez les athées.
Au contraire,
ils montreront que les athées sont souvent le type de personnes
qui pourraient servir d'honnêtes modèles aux enfants.
Le genre de personne qu'un agent publicitaire pourrait utiliser pour recommander un produit.
Le genre de personnes qui sont assis dans cette pièce.
Il devrait y avoir un effet boule de neige, une rétroaction positive,
plus nous auront de noms, plus nous en gagneront.
Il pourrait y avoir des non-linéarités, des effets de seuil.
Quand une masse critique aurait été atteinte,
il y aurait une accélération brutale du recrutement.
Encore une fois, cela demandera de l'argent.
Je suspecte le mot "athée" lui même
de contenir ou d'être un obstacle
disproportionné par rapport à sa signification réelle, et un obstacle pour des personnes
qui pourraient par ailleurs être heureuses de se dévoiler.
Quels autres mots pourrions nous donc utiliser pour préparer la route,
faire avaler la pilule, faciliter les choses? Darwin préférait agnostique
et pas seulement pour des raisons de loyauté envers son ami Huxley, qui inventa ce mot.
Darwin a dit, "Je n'ai jamais été athée
au sens de nier l'existence d'un Dieu.
Je pense que de façon générale, agnostique
serait la description la plus juste de mon état d'esprit".
Il devint même étonnamment susceptible avec Edward Aveling.
Aveling était un athée militant
qui échoua à persuader Darwin
d'accepter la dédicace de son livre sur l'athéisme,
donnant lieu accessoirement à un mythe fascinant
selon lequel Karl Marx tenta de dédicacer "Das Kapital" à Darwin,
ce qui est faux. C'était en réalité Edward Aveling.
En fait la maîtresse d'Aveling était la fille de Marx,
et quand Darwin et Marx disparurent,
les papiers de Marx furent mélangés à ceux d'Aveling
et une lettre de Darwin disant "Mon cher Monsieur, merci beaucoup
mais je ne veux pas que vous me dédicaciez votre livre"
fut considérée comme étant adressé à Marx par erreur,
et cela donna lieu à ce mythe, dont vous avez probablement entendu parler.
C'est une sorte de mythe urbain,
Marx essayant de dédicacer Le Capital à Darwin.
Quoiqu'il en soit, c'était Aveling, et quand ils se rencontrèrent, Darwin défia Aveling,
"Pourquoi vous appelez-vous athées?"
"Agnostique", répliqua Aveling, "est simplement athée avec un mandat de respectabilité,
et athée est simplement agnostique avec un mandat d'agressivité".
Darwin se plaint, "Mais pourquoi devriez-vous être si agressif ?"
Darwin pensait que l'athéisme pouvait être bon pour l'intelligentsia,
mais que les gens ordinaires n'étaient pas, je cite, "mûrs pour ça".
Ce qui est, bien sûr, notre vieil ami l'argument "ne jouez pas les trouble-fêtes".
L'histoire ne dit pas si Aveling dit à Darwin de descendre de ses grands chevaux.
(Rires)
Mais quoi qu'il en soit, c'était il y a plus de 100 ans,
vous pourriez penser que nous aurions grandit depuis.
Un ami, un juif intelligent et non pratiquant
qui accessoirement suit le shabbat
pour des raisons de solidarité culturelle,
se décrit comme un "agnostique de la petite souris".
Il ne se qualifiera pas d'athée
car il est théoriquement impossible de prouver une négation
mais le terme agnostique lui-même pourrait suggérer que l'existence de Dieu
est aussi probable que sa non-existence.
Mon ami est donc strictement agnostique à propos de la petite souris,
mais elle n'est pas très probable, n'est ce pas ? Comme Dieu.
D'où l'expression, "agnostique de la petite souris",
mais Bertrand Russell a eu la même remarque
en utilisant une hypothétique théière en orbite autour de Mars.
Strictement parlant, vous devriez être agnostique
sur la question de l'existence d'une théière en orbite autour de Mars,
mais cela ne signifie pas que vous considériez la probabilité de son existence
comme étant égale à celle de sa non-existence.
La liste des choses à propos desquelles nous devons être agnostique strictement parlant
ne s'arrête pas aux petites souris et aux théières. Elle est infinie.
Si vous voulez en croire une en particulier,
les licornes, les petites souris, les théières ou Yahvé,
il vous incombe de le justifier.
Il n'incombe pas au reste d'entre nous de dire pourquoi nous n'y croyons pas.
Nous, les athées, sommes aussi des a-souristes et des a-théièristes.
(Rires)
Mais nous ne prenons pas la peine de le dire,
et c'est pourquoi mon ami utilise agnostique de la petite souris
comme étiquette pour ce que la plupart des gens appelleraient athée.
Néanmoins, si nous voulons donner envie aux athées convaincus de se dévoiler publiquement,
nous allons devoir trouver quelque chose de mieux
à coller sur notre bannière que agnostique de la petite souris ou de la théière.
Pourquoi pas humaniste ?
Il y a l'avantage d'avoir un réseau mondial d'organisations et de journaux bien organisés
et d'autres choses déjà mises en place.
Mon problème avec cette appellation est son anthropocentrisme.
Une des choses que nous avons appris de Darwin
est que l'espèce humaine n'est qu'une
parmi des millions de cousins, certains proches, d'autres lointains.
Il y a d'autres possibilités, comme naturaliste.
Mais cela conduit aussi à des confusions,
car Darwin aurait pensé naturaliste,
naturaliste bien entendu, par opposition à surnaturaliste.
C'est utilisé parfois.
Darwin aurait été troublé par l'autre sens de naturaliste,
ce qu'il était, bien entendu, et je suppose qu'il pourrait y en avoir d'autres
qui le confondrait avec nudisme.
(Rires)
De telles personnes pourraient appartenir à ces lyncheurs anglais
qui ont attaqué l'an dernier un pédiatre en le confondant avec un pédophile.
(Rires)
Je pense que la meilleure des alternatives pour athée est simplement non-croyant.
Il n'y a pas de forte connotation qu'il n'existe pas de Dieu,
et ce mot pourrait donc être facilement adopté par les agnostiques de la petite souris ou de la théière.
Il est entièrement compatible avec le Dieu des physiciens.
Quand des gens comme... quand des athées
comme Stephen Hawking ou Albert Einstein utilisent le mot Dieu,
il l'utilisent évidemment comme une métaphore, un raccourci
pour cette mystérieuse et profonde part de la physique que nous ne comprenons pas encore.
Non-croyant sera parfait pour toutes ces raisons, et contrairement à athée,
il ne déclenche pas les mêmes réactions phobiques et hystériques.
Mais en fait je pense que l'alternative
est d'utiliser le mot athée,
précisément car il s'agit d'un mot tabou
véhiculant des frissons et des phobies hystériques.
La masse critique pourrait être plus difficile à atteindre avec le mot athée
qu'avec le mot non-croyant,
ou tout autre terme évitant la confrontation.
Mais si nous réussissons avec ce mot effrayant, athée,
l'impact politique serait encore plus important.
Alors, j'ai dit que si j'étais religieux, j'aurais très peur de l'évolution. J'irais plus loin.
J'aurais peur de la science en général qui serait bien comprise.
Et ceci est dû au fait que la vision du monde scientifique
est tellement plus passionante, plus poétique,
plus remplie de pur émerveillement
que tout ce pauvre arsenal de l'imaginaire religieux.
Comme un autre héros mort récemment, Carl Sagan, le disait,
"Comment se fait-il qu'aucune des religions majeures n'ait regardé la science
et se soit dit, "C'est mieux que ce nous que pensions !
L'univers est bien plus grand que notre prophète nous le disait,
plus majestueux, plus subtil, plus élégant" ? Au contraire elles disent "Non, non, non !
Mon dieu est un petit dieu, et je veux qu'il reste ainsi."
Une religion, ancienne ou nouvelle,
qui insisterait sur la grandeur de l'univers
tel que révélé par la science moderne
pourrait être capable de mobiliser des réserves de respect et de crainte
à peine touchées par les fois conventionnelles."
Bien, c'est un auditoire d'élite,
et je m'attends donc à ce qu'à peu près 10 pour-cent d'entre vous soyez croyant.
Beaucoup d'entre vous souscrivez probablement à l'opinion polie selon laquelle nous devrions respecter la religion,
mais je suspecte aussi bon nombre de ceux là
de secrètement mépriser la religion autant que moi.
(Rires)
Si vous êtes l'un d'entre eux, et bien sûr beaucoup d'entre vous pourraient ne pas l'être,
mais si vous êtes l'un d'entre eux, je vous demande d'arrêter d'être poli,
sorte du placard et exprimez vous, et si par hasard vous êtes riches,
réfléchissez aux moyens de changer les choses.
Le lobby religieux dans ce pays
est financé massivement par des fondations, pour ne rien dire de tous les avantages fiscaux,
par des fondations telles que la fondation Templeton et le Discovery Institute.
Nous avons besoin qu'un anti-Templeton s'avance.
Si tous mes livres se vendaient aussi bien que les livres de Stephen Hawkins,
au lieu de ne se vendre que comme ceux de Richard Dawkins, je le ferais moi-même.
Les gens demandent toujours "Le 11 septembre vous a-t-il changé ?"
Eh bien, voila en quoi cela m'a changé.
Cessons tous d'être si diablement respectueux.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)